Speaker 1: OK, let's go next. Where are we
going to go? How about Garret from Buffalo?
Garrett from Buffalo, you're on the air.
Hey, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Oh, awesome, sorry.
Thanks for having me. I really appreciate it.
Pleasure. So my question pertains to student
debt because it's been such a big issue this
year. Sure. I just had this crazy idea that
was like if Donald Trump's like, supported
canceling student debt that it really could
make a big rift in the Democratic Party. I
mean, at least in the people, the voters. And
I was just wondering your thoughts on that topic.
Speaker 1: I think you're completely right. Let's
hope he doesn't think of it. You know, I mean, I
don't know that I don't see Trump coming up with
that. But I agree with you that at this point,
cancelation of student debt has become such a
topic of interest on the left, which the right is
basically against. I mean, understand that that
if Trump came out in favor of canceling student
debt, it would go against all the principles of
the right of supposed personal responsibility
you choose. You chose to take the debt. We're
not going to bail you out all these different
Speaker 2: things and on a lot of things that
Speaker 1: keep on. But Trump has done it on
some other things. I think it would absolutely
fracture the Democratic Party, and so I hope Trump
doesn't come up with it now. That being said,
it is an undeniable fact that Joe Biden has
canceled more student debt than any former
any other president. Now you might say, Wait, but
David, he didn't do it. He didn't do it. No. Biden
has canceled student debt for certain attendees,
a for profit colleges and through some other
programs in terms of dollars. No one has canceled
more student debt than Joe Biden. He has not done
this thing that people want him to do, which is,
Hey, everybody gets 10 grand taken off of their
debt or everybody gets 50 grand taken off of the
debt. He has not done that. It has been targeted.
But I think if Trump were to come forward and
say I will cancel all student debt or something,
Joe Biden would be able to say no one's
canceled more student debt than me,
and he would technically be correct.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that makes sense,
and even if Trump did say that, do you think
it would push Biden to like, maybe do it,
maybe in the end? Maybe so. Yeah. All right.
Thanks for answering my question. I appreciate
Speaker 1: it. Yeah, my pleasure. Interesting
idea there from from from Garrett. Wow.